The ocean is a terrifying place.
We’ve all heard the statistics.
More than 80 percent of the ocean remains
unexplored.
That’s most of the water covering the globe,
completely unmapped and unobserved by science.
It’s a scary thought to dwell on, realizing
there’s more water than land on earth, and
the sheer expanse of that water is so large
that we’ve been unable to fully explore
all of it.
Just think, there are places in the ocean
that have never been seen by a human.
Who knows what’s down there?
If there were ever a personification of the
fear of the unknown, the ocean could definitely
be it.
Ancient shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor,
unknown sea creatures hiding away from humanity,
and the general isolation of the suffocating
dark blue the ocean swallows its victims with,
all of these are images that come to mind
when thinking about the vast and mysterious
depths of the sea.
And no one is more familiar with nautical
mysteries than the SCP Foundation.
Today we’ll be taking a look at SCP-5007,
the Bass Strait, a wave of oceanic anomalies
fit to make any seasoned sailor shiver in
fear.
is an area of ocean dividing Tasmania and
the Australian mainland.
It’s also the location of an unusually high
amount of disappearances.
Sailors disappearing from their ships, fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming back,
even civilians disappearing from the shores
that connect to the Strait.
The Foundation was aware of these disappearances
since 1858, but were only able to craft theories
about what was causing them.
Was it an anomalous group of interest?
Hostile aerial entities patrolling the skies
above the Strait?
Phenomena associated with unidentified flying
objects?
What about subterranean anomalies,weather
patterns, or time dilation?
For nearly a century, the Foundation was unable
to determine the cause of the high number
of disappearances in the Bass Strait, and
then, the phenomena suddenly revealed itself.
In 1980, on a beach connected to the strait,
Agent Taberner, an operative of the SCP Foundation,
was vacationing with his wife, Mary, and his
three young children.
The Taberner family was simply enjoying their
day, when they saw what looked like balloons
in the sky.
They were approaching quickly, and naturally,
the family moved closer.
What happened next was a whirlwind, and those
balloons the family was so interested in lifted
them up from the ground, and carried them
away.
Agent Taberner tried to fight back, but there
was nothing he could do, except report to
the Foundation what had occurred.
And the organization responded in full force.
The Foundation’s research discovered that
reports of UFOs and lights in the sky had
coincided with many disappearances in the
Strait, and that this was a pattern.
The search for the four lost Taberner family
members had become a large-scale investigation
into unexplained disappearances along the
Bass Strait, and within 3 weeks, it was determined
that these patterns were consistent across
the entirety of the Strait’s coastal regions.
Some witnesses were interviewed, but the vast
majority of these abduction cases had no witnesses
whatsoever.
Of the minimal reports filed, the Foundation
was told that there were lights in the sky,
and the appearance of unidentified flying
objects described as having the appearance
of balloons.
One such witness interviewed was a man by
the name of Alan Stewart, a witness who was
present during the disappearance of former
Australian Prime Minister Harold Holt, whose
disappearance the Foundation believed may
have had a connection to the Bass Strait anomalies.
During the interview, Stewart claimed that
Holt and his family, while voyaging on their
yacht, decided to leave the boat and go for
a swim.
Holt turned to Stewart and asked him if he
could see the balloons around the cliff.
Stewart had no idea what Holt was talking
about, but Holt was insistent on seeing them.
He swam deeper out into the ocean, saying
that they weren’t normal balloons, and that
there was someone inside of them.
Stewart and Holt’s family called out for
him to come to shore, but he wouldn’t listen.
Stewart tried to rationalize what he saw next.
Maybe it was the current sweeping Holt away.
But he couldn’t lie to the Foundation interviewer.
Stewart saw Holt go further and further out
into the water, and suddenly, the Prime Minister
turned around.
He began swimming in the opposite direction.
And he was screaming.
Suddenly, Holt was lifted from the sea and
pulled into the air by something emerging
from the clouds.
The Foundation thanked Stewart for the interview,
and continued their investigation.
Two years later, in 1982, emergency services
received a large number of calls pertaining
to UFO sightings off the coast of Norman Bay,
Victoria.
The Foundation was quick to respond, alerting
task forces and local sites to prepare for
an investigation.
Upon arriving at the scene, they confirmed
the existence of multiple entities that would
later be documented as SCP-5007.
They evacuated civilians from the area and
successfully managed to capture the creature,
which was later transported to Site-40 for
containment.
It was a sight to behold.
The entity, now designated SCP-5007-S1, was
a cluster of human bodies fused between a
grouping of black tentacles of varying length.
Each tentacle was fused to the skin it touched
directly.
The stomachs of the corpses were grossly swollen
and distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gasses inside, the buoyancy
of which the entity used to achieve a passive
flight.
Across the entity’s surface were clusters
of eyes and bioluminescent, glowing organs.
Many of the humanoid components of the corpses
appeared to have been removed and misplaced
across various parts of the entity’s body.
What’s more, is that the Foundation discovered
that the human portions of SCP-5007 appeared
somewhat cognizant and aware of their situation.
Their vocalizations were incoherent and barely
understandable, consisting of gasping and
whimpering, but the corpses were observed
to implore other individuals to approach them
when encountered.
SCP-5007’s behavior during abduction scenarios
was documented during the initial containment
event, and due to the Foundation’s painstaking
research, a pattern was established between
all SCP-5007 encounters.
First, the victim would be alone, or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location.
SCP-5007 haven’t shown a preference for
weather, be they clear or hostile skies, but
they have localized all of their activity
to the Bass Strait, in small coastal towns,
beaches, or boats.
SCP-5007 will then move towards the shore,
stalking the victim before lowering its tentacles
and appendages to grab the individual, snatching
them into the sky.
An SCP-5007 instance can even abduct multiple
people at once.
One event observed had eight men from the
decks of a commercial fishing boat taken into
the sky in under 15 seconds.
Once captured, SCP-5007 instances will dart
across the water at a high speed, and take
their victims to an unknown location.
Discovering where SCP-5007 took their victims
became a top priority for the Foundation.
After extensive witness interviews and compiling
a database of likely victims, they determined
there must be at least 16 instances of SCP-5007
unaccounted for.
Personnel kept a close watch on the coastlines
and waters of the Bass Strait, and equipped
various marine task forces with research vessels
capable of tracking any instances if they
encountered them.
In 1985, the Foundation’s research efforts
paid off, and several survey teams operating
in the area reported a sighting of an extremely
large SCP-5007 instance heading towards a
coastal town.
A Mobile Task force was sent to track the
entity.
The team observed the entity from afar as
it stalked a private fishing boat.
Even from the distance, Foundation personnel
recognized the likenesses of several missing
persons as faces on the corpses of SCP-5007.
The Task force captain had to remind his team
to keep it together, claiming that they were
not people, but just parts of the specimen.
But everyone secretly knew the truth.
The fishing vessel was a private one, occupied
by a small family.
The entity slowly approached, and quickly
pulled a woman into the air.
The family panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety, running into the ship’s
cabin.
The entity ran its tentacles along the boat
until it pulled the door open, snatching another
two victims.
The task force was unable to help them, as
their mission was to track the instance to
its origin point.
It was a horror to watch.
The task force implanted a tracking beacon
onto the entity, and quietly followed it out
to sea over the next four hours.
They then discovered a large, gray reef, with
several shipwrecks dotted across it.13 SCP-5007
instances floated over the area, some holding
onto the land-reef with their tentacles.
The entity dropped the abductees from the
fishing boat, who were coerced by the entities
into diving into a massive pool of water located
in the center of the reef.
One by one, each abductee was pulled below
the surface by something lurking inside the
pool.
All while the SCP-5007 instances watched.
Disgusted, the task force reported what they
observed to the main site, and the reef would
be designated as SCP-5007-A.
The Foundation’s analysis of the reef led
to the discovery that the rock covering it
seeped iron oxide from an unknown source,
and the rocks achieved growth at an anomalously
fast rate, often as little as 40 minutes.
All of the wrecked ships and aircraft that
washed across the shore of the reef were covered
with the dark stone.
The reef was teeming with anomalous marine
life, including SCP-5007, a red algae that
fed upon the freshly grown rock, marine worms
capable of levitation, spiders that lived
in silk retreats underneath the waterline,
small fish, and giant organisms resembling
large clumps of kelp, which the Foundation
had previously documented as SCP-4159 in a
separate investigation.
SCP-5007 often rested their tentacles on the
outcroppings of the reef while inactive.
But what caught the Foundation’s attention
the most was the giant pit located at the
reef’s center.
Unmanned exploration drones found that it
had a depth of at least 4000 meters and water
samples taken from the pit revealed large
quantities of human DNA, prehistoric bacteria,
and unknown compounds that possessed significant
life-preserving qualities.
When a being was submerged in the compound,
they were able to survive heavy injuries,
even when fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe.
The Foundation’s exploration of one of the
shipwrecks led them to a journal.
Most of it was illegible due to water damage,
but one passage survived, located in the back
of the book.
It detailed the experience of an unknown crew
member of a ship caught in a storm.
It reads:
“Moresby spied land ahead, and the boys
say there are giant balloons hanging over
the island.
We are all afeared, but there is naught we
can do but beach ourselves and hope for rescue.
Should I be killed in the crash, I want my
mates to give this journal to my Mary might
know I spent my last thinking only of her.”
The interior of the ship contained human remains
inside, but there were less skeletons than
the Foundation would expect for a ship of
its size.
The location of the rest of the bodies was
unknown.
Another event related to SCP-5007 the Foundation
documented involved
Frederick Valentich, a pilot engaged in a
training flight over the Bass Strait in 1978.
Valentich’s disappearance was marked by
his latest communication with air traffic
control, when he mistook an SCP-5007 instance
for an unidentified aircraft.
It seems like it's stationary.
What I'm doing right now is orbiting and the
thing is just orbiting on top of me.
Also it's got a green light and sort of metallic,
like it's all shiny on the outside.
Shortly after this, Valentich’s transmission
was interrupted by what was described as metallic,
scraping sounds, believed to be the SCP-5007
instance attacking the aircraft and jamming
its propellers with its mass.
After crashing into the reef, it was believed
that Valentich and his aircraft were pulled
beneath the surface of the pit, just as the
abductees had been prior.
The Foundation decided to construct a provisional
secure research facility on the reef.
They named it Site-40-R, and documented all
returns and departures of SCP-5007.
They also set up a series of containment procedures
that resulted in SCP-5007 returning with victims
83% less often then before the site’s construction.
But this was short lived.
In 2008, the site logged over thirty six instances
returning to the reef, with only two not having
any fresh abductees.
These instances' origins were unknown, and
it was as if they appeared out of thin air.
No other monitoring post had documented their
appearance, or even spotted them before they
arrived at the reef.
It was years later, in 2017, that the Foundation
eventually was able to successfully explore
what was deep inside the pit at the center
of the reef.
They already knew there was a large entity
lurking beneath, as evidenced by what happened
to the victims of SCP-5007 that were deposited
inside the pool.
All previous attempts to explore the pool
were met with failure, as the water pressure
of the pit’s depths caused all craft to
collapse due to hull damage.
This time, however, they managed to construct
a high-tech submarine, labeled the SCPS Nautilus,
which was capable of diving a maximum of 13,500
meters underwater.
They decided that a D-Class personnel would
be trained to man the submersible and carry
out the exploration.
The mission was simple.
The Nautilus was to dive to the bottom of
the pit and to describe the depth readings.
Cameras and a microphone were equipped to
the vessel.
Due to the depth, remote viewing of this footage
was impossible.
Instead, the Foundation had to physically
recollect the vessel in order to view the
footage.
Upon recovery, some of the footage suffered
data corruption, but what was there shook
those who viewed it to their core.
The footage showed the D-Class’s experience
going deeper inside the pit.
At first, it seemed ordinary.
The trench had a number of rocky outcroppings,
dotted with black-yellow vines growing along
the walls.
Also present were the various marine lifeforms,
such as the spiders or the fish.
Going deeper, the sub observed an SCP-5007
instance clinging to an outcropping.
Several tendrils emerging from the pits depths
were wrapped around the instance and holding
onto the entity, as if it were feeding from
it.
Another 16 SCP-5007 instances were seen resting
along the walls, each clinging to the outcropping.
As the sub went deeper, the D-Class remarked
that there were dozens of plane and shipwrecks,
but also well over a hundred SCP-5007 entities.
Most of them were held there by the black
tendrils.
The D-Class, as the sub went even deeper,
began noticing human remains.
No short amount of them, either.
Deep into the pit, there was a large mass
of human remains, covering the entirety of
the pit.
Bodies crushed and drained of blood, but still
possessing intact eyes.
Each individual was still alive, kept preserved
by the life-sustaining compounds found within
the water.
The bodies stared at the sub and moved, attempting
to grab onto the vehicle.
The D-Class swore they were trying to say
something, mouthing words to the camera of
the sub.
As the sub passed through the mass of bodies,
it emerged into a completely dark, black clearing
at the bottom of the pit.
For a second, the D-Class thought he was safe.
But then, a large black tentacle rapidly emerged
from below and grabbed onto the Nautilus,
dragging it even further into the depths.
The D-Class screamed and panicked, but there
was nothing he could do.
The tentacle possessed large clusters of eyes,
mouths, and human heads seemingly grafted
onto its mass.
And then there was another tentacle, and then
another.
The Nautilus was pulled to the bottom of the
pool.
The D-Class’s screams were still heard,
even as the picture cut out.
Sometimes, graphic, body-alerting images of
the tentacle's features were visible on the
screen, but most of the footage was indecipherable.
After minutes of distorted, corrupted footage,
the Nautilus was seen again, rapidly ascending
to the surface.
Somehow, it had managed to escape the entity
at the bottom of the pit.
Upon recovery of the craft, it was found that
the Nautilus was covered in a thick, organic
coating similar to a black slime mold, but
with dozens of eyes growing from it.
The D-Class inside showed severe psychological
damage and attempted to harm Foundation personnel.
They were terminated shortly after, due to
being a danger to those around them.
Following review of the footage, the Nautilus
was to be dismantled and incinerated, alongside
the remains of the D-Class.
A reinforced containment seal was fitted over
the pit, with the intention of keeping whatever
was down there isolated from the surface.
But this was short lived.
After the containment seal was fitted, Site-40
underwent a massive communications blackout.
Every device on the site received an email
containing a single image of a large eye,
taken from a security camera.
The text beneath it simply read “FOUND YOU”.
Some personnel who viewed the email underwent
anomalous changes, growing new physical features,
such as eyes and other various growths, across
their body.
The entirety of Site-40-R went offline, and
the Foundation could not establish contact.
In an emergency effort to do so, Mobile Task
Force Gamma-6, Deep Feeders, was sent to investigate.
The task force’s assault on Site-40-R was
a daring effort, as the majority of the site
was completely overtaken by tentacles, growths,
and anomalous alterations.
While numerous altered personnel were lost
during the mission, it was ultimately a success.
Some altered personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove their
anomalous growths.
And after everything was said and done, the
site was repaired and reconstructed without
incident.
Following the site’s repair, there has been
little activity from the entity within the
pit, but the Foundation continues to keep
an eye on the creature and the ecosystem of
the anomalous marine life that live on the
Bass Strait, never knowing what their next
move might be, and always keeping in mind
the risk that comes with dealing with these
poorly-understood entities.
Now go check out “SCP-3000 - Anantashesha”
and “SCP-057-IT - Under the Sea” for more
anomalous entities living, breathing and thriving
in the depths of the unknown!